somebody is really stressed out they're
not stressed out for no reason it's
because they're focusing on something
that makes them feel stressed
when i have a difficult day here's one
of the first things i do a lot of people
are stressed right now why
text phone mobile radio tv facebook
uh twitter all this it's just non-stop
stress in the brain
wanna be happy live a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the 10 ways to be
less stressed enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one change your state with
tony robbins if somebody is we're
mentioning earlier if somebody is really
stressed out
they're not stressed out for no reason
it's because they're focusing on
something that makes them feel stressed
they often when they're focusing on it
it changes the body you start to feel
tight you start to feel a certain way
and then they use language like i don't
know what to do why am i so overwhelmed
so three things control how you feel
every moment what you focus on
what you do with your body if your
shoulders are down if you're breathing
like ah
it's not hard to figure out you're not
going to be in a very resourceful state
if i take that same person and change
their body radically
i get them to talk at a different tempo
i get them to move their body
differently
i've taught this for what 41 years
three years ago at harvard they did a
study on power postures where they
showed that if you
stand like this with your hands on your
hips like superman or wonder woman
or if you lean back like this like the
guy isn't obnoxious at the office and do
this
it literally changes your testosterone
by 25
within two minutes it reduces cortisol
which you know is the stress hormone
by 30 and you're 33 more likely to take
an action
so if we change what we focus on if we
change the way we use our body if we
change our language patterns
we'll instantly feel different things
how do people use their body when
they're worried versus when they're
excited
if you learn to use your body first use
your focus first you can literally
change how you feel moments and then you
develop new habits where you start to
feel good all the time
and it isn't some phony fake pump up
it's literally the way you've
conditioned your body just like being
fit as an athlete you want to be
emotionally fit
way number two move with robin sharma
when i have a difficult day here's one
of the first things i do i will get on
my mountain bike
and i will ride like a bat out of
wherever
through the forest and that releases
dopamine
in my brain which is the
neurotransmitter of inspiration
and that releases serotonin moving right
on the bicycle it releases serotonin
which is the pleasure neurotransmitter
and it cuts down on my cortisol which is
the fear
hormone so just simply going for a
mountain bike ride or going for a swim
or getting into yoga class or something
as simple as going for a walk or maybe
even doing
jumping jacks when no one's looking
will create a pharmacy of mastery within
your brain
which will affect your psychology your
neurobiology
and your interior life which makes you
just feel a lot better you know that
after a workout you always feel
different than you did before you went
into the workout and related to a
pharmacy of mastery
is something that i have counted on for
years
when i've had good seasons when i've had
challenging seasons of my life
massage i call it the two massage
protocol
two massages every single week it
moves your lymph it moves your blood
which oxygenates your system
it reduces toxicity you feel a whole lot
better
way number three turn stress on itself
with jocko willing
there's been thousands
and hundreds of thousands and millions
of warriors that have been
in very stressful situations
faced evil and faced death much
worse than the situation
i'm in or urine that we might consider
stressful and i even did this when i was
overseas when i was on deployment when i
was a combat leader
i was feeling stress and you know what
we took casualties and it was awful and
it was
heartbreaking and
but there were other
soldiers and warriors throughout time
that have been in much worse situations
gettysburg or vicksburg or the battle
the bulge
and in all those
horrible situations
they prove really that humans can
withstand
almost almost unimaginable stress
which meant to me that i could too
and you can
and and the first step for me is doing
that taking that
look to gain some perspective
and then in order to gain perspective
you got to do something that we already
talked about you've gotta detach you've
gotta detach from the problems or the
stress that you're experiencing
so that you can get that perspective of
them
now
there's a couple different types of
stress now if it's
something that you can control that's
causing you stress
well why aren't you getting control of
it now there's also stress that's caused
by things that you cannot control
and if you remember talking earlier
about artillery and how
horrible that was and what made it so
horrible was that
there's no control over so if you can't
control something
and you can't get control of it
you have to at least
embrace what you can and i'm not saying
you're going to embrace
artillery shelling but i'll tell you
what when it comes to things like
artillery or for us in ramadi was ieds
and we could do everything we could do
to mitigate that risk but eventually
there's only so much you can do and you
cannot completely eliminate it
but you can't control it so why are you
gonna worry about it
why are you gonna stress about it
if there's something that's completely
beyond your control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it
and on top of that
if it's something that you can't control
how can you look at it in a different
light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it
how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of ally
you know the the chaos of combat
is something that i couldn't control but
i had to embrace it so i could try and
figure out how to take advantage of it
so when it comes to stress
don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it
use it use it to make yourself sharper
and more alert and use it to make
yourself
think more and learn more and get better
and use that stress
as a catalyst to make yourself
better way number four disconnect with
john ashraf
a lot of people are stressed right now
why text phone
mobile radio tv facebook uh twitter all
this
it's just non-stop stress in the brain
and when the brain feels stressed then
obviously cortisone
cortisone cortisol epinephrine
norepinephrine kick in and that's a
stress hormone
well it's like having you know your
finger on the electricity button all day
long and just not not stopping so you
start to burn
the fibers your nerves hey this is john
asref and do you love good books
i love to read because there's so much
wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research
pay 15 20 bucks and you learn so much
now i'm reading this awesome book called
built to serve
find your purpose and become the leader
you were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star way number five embrace
stress and pressure with tom bilyeu that
steve jobs quote that the world is made
by people no smarter than you
is actually true and so if you're
believing that these people are smarter
than you because you did bad on your
sats i'm just going to tell you right
now stop
so you can develop yourself so my
obsession became that humans are the
ultimate adaptation machine we
are literally wired from the ground up
in order to grow and improve under
stress and pressure
so it's like what's the phrase uh
pressure can burst pipes but it also
creates diamonds
so it's like you need the pressure and
yes it can hurt
but it can also make something amazing
if you're willing to put yourself in
that situation so
it's a weird twist of fate that humans
um
in order to build the muscle you first
have to tear it right yeah so
but once you accept that that's how it
works you can do extraordinary things
way number six get consumed by
positivity with garugapaldas
get consumed by the positive energy
focus
not on your bad habits get consumed
not by the negative energy of your bad
habit sometimes we just get so consumed
by it that all that's playing on our
mind is that
no that's meant to be dealt with
focus on the good things that are
happening in your life
and to focus on the good things and be
grateful doesn't happen automatically
it's not our default setting our default
setting is to go towards the negative
our default setting is it to focus on
the negative
we have to customize our lives by being
consciously aware
we have to become more mindful and
conscious of the wonderful
gifts the wonderful opportunities the
wonderful
blessings that we've been showered with
and with that
positive energy with that
positive emotion of gratitude
feel tremendously empowered
to deal with our bad habits to deal with
our challenges
and therefore do not be hateful about
what you're going through in life
be grateful for all those
wonderful gifts that you've been given
in your life
way number seven don't put pressure on
yourself with marie forleo
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
in the last decade for you
that things first of all keep getting
better
i think in our society especially as
relates to
you know as you get older at least in my
family
there was a lot of kind of cultural
expectations like oh
over this age it kind of starts going
down or you know what i mean you're kind
of
you peak when you're young and that's
when all the good stuff happens and for
me
i feel like it keeps getting better and
i
love that the best years are still ahead
of me
and that all the stuff that i've been
through there's like all of these
exciting new possibilities
so that's one of the biggest lessons and
i think the other one is that i don't
have to stress as hard like
as a human being i have a really strong
work ethic
but i also tend to put a lot of pressure
on myself
and the other lesson i've learned is
that i don't need to do that
that the work actually gets done more
joyfully and more creatively
if i don't add on that additional layer
of pressure
and stress way number eight endure
stress with radhanath swami
stress it seems to follow us
at every turn in life through timeless
wisdom
we could learn to transform stress
into a positive energy that inspires
personal fulfillment and heightened
productivity
the same stress that pummels us into
anxiety
has the potential to increase the value
of life
physically emotionally and spiritually
stress can break us or strengthen us
an athlete grows in speed and strength
through enduring stress
for example when lifting weights the
greater the resistance
the stronger the weight lifter becomes
however if not balanced properly the
stress of the weight
could injure your back or damage your
muscles
properly managed even the stress
of taking exams in school can be an
impetus to serious study
the queen of gems the precious diamond
is nothing but common coal
that with the help of nature's wisdom
has been
transformed under extreme pressure
and gold the king of metals is
purified by blazing fire
integrity means to embrace our ideals
even in the face of temptation or fear
and to become a more compassionate human
being
in the process but how does that happen
how can we transform stress from a
hurtful energy
to a helpful energy the bible tells
us that if you build your house on a
foundation
of rock then whatever storms may come
the house will not be moved but if you
build your house
on a foundation of sand
may look beautiful but when a storm
comes
it will collapse the timeless wisdom
of the bhagavad-gita explains that this
foundation is the inner peace
and love that is the very nature of our
soul and our true potential way number
nine
control your awareness with dandapani
when i was growing up
i had met my guru when i was about 21.
and
i was going to join his monastic order
which was in hawaii
i was at that time living in western
australia and
studying in university and i remember in
my last year of engineering
i was feeling extremely stressed i had a
thesis which i'd been working on for a
year and a half that i needed to
complete
in the next month i had about seven or
eight examinations that i had to pass in
order to graduate as an engineer
i was the president of the youth group
of our temple over that
local temple over there and we were
organizing a lot of different events and
i was also dancing
as part of a dance company that i was
involved in
and they were also putting up a big show
so we were rehearsing almost every night
and i remember emailing my guru saying
gurudeva i'm really stressed i have all
these things going on
[Music]
and i'm stressed he emailed me back and
i don't remember the exact words that he
he used but he emailed me back and said
the reason you're stressed is because
you don't keep your awareness on one
thing at a time
and i'll be absolutely honest with you
ever since that day i've never felt
stressed anymore
and i know it's a very bold proclamation
to make but it's true
because i clearly understood what he
said to me at that point
whenever i was dancing i was thinking
about my thesis and when i was working
on my thesis i was thinking about the
exams i had to do and i was thinking
working on my exams
when i was studying for my exams i was
thinking about the youth group
and wherever i was i was thinking about
something else
anxiety comes because we allow awareness
to drift away
from the present moment and go into the
future or into the past
in an uncontrolled way so the past and
the future are not bad things as long as
we indulge in them or we enter them
with the aim to learn from them
but we don't we just allow awareness to
travel into the past and the future
all the time it creates anxiety and we
do that because we're afraid
anxiety comes out of a sense of fear
where we allow awareness to go into the
future
we create a situation that hasn't
happened
we bring it back into the present and
start living it
as it has already happened you keep
repeating the process
over and over and over again you build
anxiety
i'm gonna get sick i'm gonna get sick
you think in the future what if i get
sick
then what happens oh my god i'm gonna
get sick and then you bring back the
present and you start living that
five minutes later you let your
awareness go into the future and you
think for yourself
i'm not gonna get better i'm gonna get
sick and then you bring awareness back
into the present again
and you start worrying about it you keep
repeating this process over and over
again
and you build anxiety so the way to get
overcome stress
and anxiety is to really control where
your awareness goes
every time your awareness goes into the
future or into the past
in an uncontrolled way bring it back to
the present again
and just do this exercise be mindful of
this throughout the entire day
don't let your awareness go into the
past or into the future
in an uncontrolled way and way number 10
the last one before very special bonus
clip
is practice stress management with jim
quick and finally number 10
what i try to practice every single day
is stress management
you know so one if you want to know what
the biggest obstacle is for people's
brains
is stress stress creates cortisol
adrenal in your body
it's really good for fight or flight
it's not really good if you need to take
a test
it's not really good if you need to
study it's not really have to read
reports and journals and learn something
brand new or learn a language
sure because that'll that'll shut down
parts of your brain wow so those are the
10 things that i focus on every single
day
that's what's going to move the needle
more than anything now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
i love the idea of reframing a negative
situation into a positive one
it can really serve you it reminds me of
what tony robbins said
of you look at the worst thing that's
ever happened to your life and
ask yourself how can this worst thing
ever be the best thing ever
how do you reframe it so that the most
negative situation ever in your life
becomes your biggest strength becomes
your mission helps you follow
something that didn't have a bigger
impact i really think that for people
who get through
a negative situation it makes him a lot
stronger just as a human being
and quite often the mission that we have
in our lives the things that we want to
contribute and give back
is so that other people don't have to
face the same consequences the same
suffering
that we faced so for me i love helping
entrepreneurs
i love it it fuels me it drives me
what's the big reason for it was because
i struggled so much
as an entrepreneur that i want to make
it easier for other people who are like
me
and if you're looking for your mission
just go back to previous pain that
you've dealt with
and how you've gotten through it quite
often what you want to do is it is then
make it
easier for people to not have to suffer
through the same pain figure out what
you stand for figure out what your one
word is figure out
what's at the core of you figure out
what your mission is and then any
negative situation that happens
you can reframe it to one that's
empowering for you the one that serves
you the ones that builds you up and can
inspire others around you as well
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want to know how tony robbins says
you should deal with depression check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there